des hommes en combinaison intégrale qui
pulvérise dans les rues une solution
afin d'éliminer virus et bactéries une
scène qui se retrouvent dans un nombre
croissant de communes notamment elles
ont cours ici à un arrêt de bus dans le
quartier de la clé de saint pierre on a
trouvé que c'était important de
travailler sur tout ce qui est mobile et
urbain alors soit pour les transports ou
les meilleurs d'un traditionnel bancs
poubelles et autres qui peuvent être
utilisés par les agents pour toi il y en
a estimé qu' effectivement ça peut être
une source de propagation du virus donc
on souhaite venir nettoyer la ville qui
précise respecter les règles
environnementales effectivement une
solution à base de chlore sont des
solutions qu'on utilise déjà notamment
dans des cantines des choses comme ça
qui sont adaptés qui sont diluées dans
l'eau
l'idée c'est de faire un premier passage
pour nettoyer le site et après un
massage effectivement à grande envergure
donc on veut pas faire n'importe quoi
soyons vigilants
il ya suffisamment de problèmes déjà
avec ce virus
pour l'instant il ne s'agit que d'une
première phase qui ne concernent
notamment que les centres commerciaux et
les lieux encore fréquenté la réflexion
est en cours pour une opération de plus
grande envergure
la fréquence sera seul d'une fois par
semaine on va être à l'hebdomadaire et
on verra en fonction de l'avancée s'il
ya nécessité de faire un peu plus une
initiative qui ne se substitue pas aux
gestes barrières mais qui pourrait
permettre en tout cas de rassurer un peu
la population